thank you good afternoon everyone yeah
it's a bit optimistic now to say that
we'll be generating code right now from
the nature language but that's something
that we are trying to get see yeah so my
name is Misha and I'm a physicist by
training and basically spend more my
career in academia trying to build
models that would explain us how the
complex system really wolf from
hydrodynamics atmospheric dynamics and
like neurobiology so I am NOT a
developer and what you will hear about
the code right now is basically my
adventure and what I really have seen in
code and the intelligence we were able
to get but just from analyzing it using
different mathematical models and I hope
it will be interesting for you so let me
start with this question I think if not
everyone is a software engineer here at
least everyone codes right who is not
who who didn't write they'd be the
single line of code in this auditorium
is this such a person no there are no
such people ok so this this question
should be valid for you so how much time
do you thinks of engineers codes who
thinks that
who thinks more than 50 percent of their
time so you all think that it's less
than 50 percent we so actually you are
very right and amazingly software
engineers spend about five to twenty
eight percent so the word to study is
very recently won from Microsoft
Research that said that software
engineers spent for authoring and
co-authoring about 28 percent of that
time bit more detailed study from
actually from a ceviche in Singapore
showed that only 5% slope engineers
spend on coding the rest they either
just communicate to each other or they
try to understand what's actually has
been written before so which is like
about 60% of the time
so like since pretty much every one of
you probably familiar with with the
Brooks law you understand how fast the
complexity of interactions grow actually
when when the team is growing so when
you just three developers in the syrup
is super simple to explain what's
actually going on once you once you
working in a team where there are 20
people 50 people and so on it's
extremely difficult and in meetings
understanding what has been written
before actually eats up pretty much all
of the time so imagine that if how
wonderful it will be actually if all
this problems such an unsustainable
system be solved if we have all the
patterns in our mind and how all the
different ways and how the problems
could be solved and how it has been
solved already in different ways
basically having a github in your mind
well not the old github only good part
of it obviously we will think that
something like this would be able with
with the application of write because we
live in such era where already images
and media processing and Siri and Alexa
driverless cars and unbeatable alphago
completely change our perception of the
world really so where we are right now
in terms of understanding what's
actually going on in code so because you
know sometimes reality and perception
slightly different well we are now
building blocks actually that will allow
us to get to get these treasures out of
the data to this code and what is this
what is this building blocks well very
recent research on a few of those showed
that we can get absolutely amazing
results so there's been done some work
on code completion where people
basically looked at the structure of the
code analyzed it topologically and
learnt using a deep learning and machine
learning methods then build the models
that were able to complete code
especially if everything is named
properly which is very seldomly the case
but still it it works sometimes code
optimization well basically imagine that
you write a code and you don't care
whether it's optimized for CPU usage or
even if it's like readable for by others
so there are models that help you to
optimize the code so that is it's taking
less less space less memory and so on
and so on automated code review well
this is something that quite a lot of
people spend quite a lot of time and
intelligent code reviews
using deep learning is something that is
very interesting basically when the
model look at all the the code reviews
that happen in the person recommends how
the the code reviews should happen for
your particular project bug detection
automated bug fixing I suppose it's
probably a holy grail of software
engineering projects it would be great
to solve it so right now our research is
at the stage where we can help with the
bug fixes based on like in name based
models basically so we can we can take a
look at how you name the variables and
functions and based on that help you to
the bakbox and even sometimes fix the
bug so I I did improve what one of these
models actually a bit and in in 8% of
the cases it was fixing the box with
accuracy of more than 80% so it's very
good but then very very small test cases
but very promising see and finally
documentation generation so according to
github site its most of the people they
hate writing documentation when they
even finally did write it they hate
updating it even more so it's there's
something number number one complain and
it's not just that actually so let me
ask you a question so what do you think
is the result of this run would it be
true or false who thinks it will be true
every one thing that will be false who
think it will be false okay so this
false okay what about this one what do
you think do you thing will be true good
things will be true who think it will be
false okay this is true so basically for
me is the face is this absolutely
mind-blowing and without the commutation
and this is this is a simple example of
how visa could JavaScript be and that's
why we are writing usually in academia
see or Python and worse so but this is
like this simplest one imagine like what
kind of code disasters or monsters could
be inside then without proper
documentation very difficult actually to
crack so that's why
and especially for me the code
documentation is at best when it's
stackoverflow operation so I asked a
question I go dance and with the labels
I can explain it so now in order to get
really to the translation of code or in
particular I will be talking more about
auto-generated documentation we should
first ask what is really called so code
can be seen in very different
granularity levels will be seen as a
sequence of bytes sequence of characters
sequence of tokens or as a tree so as
you can see this structure actually is
very similar to pack stacks also could
be represented pretty much more all of
all of these forms except for a tree
some may argue that tree also could be a
representation of text that's why it's
very natural to approach the problem of
ml of analysis of code from an NLP
perspective and just treat code as a s
text there's been quite a lot of studies
on on that that just took this approach
boots they all showed that this is a
tremendous oversimplification you
actually can do that but you will not
get much out of the code in this game
one of the simplest reason is because
well the regularity already is defined
in language when you will be treating
language a programming language just as
tax you will be relearning it again and
just waste a load of GPU time and money
and everything at the same time there is
a language syntax and language semantics
which are very different actually in
natural languages in code hello there
are some trade-offs but that's pretty
much the same difference so you can see
it even better on this wonderful graph
as you can see my hand was not very when
I was drawing it but you get there you
get the meaning so we see here learning
effort basically on how much training
time and data you have to invest in your
models that will be capturing the
semantics of the code basically trying
to understand what's actually going on
against and now is the analysis effort
or which is a semantic depth how much
you will actually understand about so
here on the left side you can see token
string which base
it means that you are treating call this
text you just have a string of tokens
and you analyze them then we have a tree
representation which is ast it stands
for abstract syntax tree is tree
representation of code which you can
analyze topologically may have semantics
and dependency semantic analysis
dependency graph so basically the
further you go to the right the more
language specific and task-specific your
model is becoming so you are really
getting a very good answers and a very
precise ones but and you actually don't
spend that much time on training but you
cannot use it for anything else you just
answering one isolated question the
opposite of that if you just tripped
call s text you are very language
agnostic because you don't care actually
even about the regularities of code but
then it takes you load of time to Train
any anymore and you're also losing a lot
of stuff so in order to get mmm to
represent the code you probably should
work somewhere here in the middle in the
gold middle which is basically located
around the collage achill structure of
code which is usually a st's abstract
syntax trees and go a bit further up
here and a bit down here the Pens are
always depends on the task so this graph
is probably one of the key problem it
represents one of the key problems that
people are coming back again and again
and the question is and how should you
represent the code really because in NLP
you know that there is a term of notion
of word embeddings and word embeddings
they they work with words so what should
be an Alec here should we work on on the
talking level or on the tree level or
even in a bigger and this question I
think there is no silver bullet I'll
show you a couple of approaches that
there that we did say so the first
approach that we that we did in order to
in order to generate automated
automatically generate the communication
was an unsupervised model which was
treating a code as a number of three
paths so basically imagine that you have
a tree
that represents your code and then you
go through this tree from one leaf to
another one and then as a collection of
these trees you just represented as a
continuous multi-dimensional actors and
then you feed them into model in order
to capture the semantics of what
actually is going on inside we use the
very classic libraries and build our
models on top of them as an architecture
I use the tree basal STM so basically
the version of SCM that fits very well
to the tree representation of code in
this sense it's it's very intuitive to
use it and syntax aware thickened
ization to optimize the model so as the
data I used to about 300 million lines
of code actually bit more than that from
github and it took me about two hours to
train on sixteen CPUs and two GPU so let
me show you as a demo now since the
damage they always crush so I I will use
YouTube
I hope YouTube will not crash and and
here we go
[Music]
okay so here now imagine that you are
you are a soft engineer that started a
new project which is basically a web
blogging platform right so you're just
testing testing the platform just trying
to understand what's actually going on
and it's your first day and one of the
very intuitive tests will be just to
create an article and then you hit the
box so the article is not being created
so what can you do really in order to to
understand what's going on and fix this
buck well this is now if you think oh
you can change you can go to the
repository just go through all these
files and try to read all the code and
understand what's we're really the
article is creating where the bug could
be another thing you could go to the
search bar and just type create article
it will not give you much as you can
imagine because you have to know how
exactly it's being named and whether
there is even a method name or something
like that what you could do is you could
try to run it on our engine that
actually already have all the code in
this project represented in a way that I
described to you and voila we have
exactly the point in code where the
article is being initiated so everything
here is the UC is auto-generated using
our model so you see that there is a
there is a question how to create a new
article which is describing what's
happening there in the code you have
semantic tags which create a new article
well very good that's pretty much what
we are looking for related questions so
pretty much like SEC overflow it helps
you just to navigate and to study the
context a bit more the key textual
diagrams not finished yet but the most
interesting thing is that the function
is actually called make article not
create my article and this that's not
the problem that very often is being
faces it you have to know exactly what
the name has been used in order to
identify and this is the power of
semantic search and and basically the
embeddings that in this case mostly
topological
in order to in order to get the
intelligence and bug fixes because you
can imagine here just within a couple of
minutes you were able to complete the
you you were able to
fix the box completely right okay so
what we have seen is the fee is the
following a so this is the
representation of pretty much all the
variables and method names there has
been seen in this project and if we
embedded them properly so if we did
choose to represent a mathematical
representation of everything that's
happening inside there inside the
project well or here it's actually even
across the different projects then the
the entities that are very similar
semantically say different sorting
algorithms or different features that
are related to in this case creating an
article it could be also like a password
generation or security measure the song
so on
they will be close to each other so we
could cluster them together and we will
know that this actually means pretty
much the same thing so we can treat them
as as an entity of this similar
semantics those that are dissimilar
there will be further apart from each
other and then you can just calculate
the distance whatever distance you like
a relation cosine distance anything
although the accuracy here is quite good
but even the notion of accuracy for such
problems I think is a very very
interesting path because if you read the
if you read the literature then you will
face the very classic terms which is a
precision and recall which for NLP are
called Co blue and brush and f1 school
which is basically a combination of blue
and Rouge in our case we calculated it
for sub tokens case insensitive but it
doesn't really matter so but when you
when you deal with and what is the
precision recall basically it's when for
a given piece of code you are saying
that this is about creating of creation
of new article and then you check on how
how many of these labels the motor will
generate automatically if it generates
all three then it's 1 if it doesn't
generate everything that it's 0 if there
is overlap then there is a some
percentage between 0 & 1 the problem is
that that we face we face a very
interesting challenge with false
positives and false negatives here
people my different people might treat
different tags as as significant or
insignificant differently so basically
some people might may say that for the
example that you have seen create
article will be relevant but new is not
relevant thing so for it will be
different scores actually for different
people especially when you go to a mock
more complex examples there will be a
certification of say against the
different goals so that's why we were
we're mainly calculating the relevant
score which is basically a satisfaction
metrics how satisfied the users with
with what we explained them inside the
code in natural language and this is
very tricky on how you can calculate it
actually because the the the relevant
the relevant score and f1 are not
directly correlated actually so you can
you can you can improve your models and
you can see the improvement on on all
the classic metrics but the users will
still will not be very satisfied so
there are other problems with there with
unsupervised approach here and one of
them is that there is not enough depth
so as you have seen the create and make
yes we can catch it which is very nice
but in this example for example look
there is this there is this element
which is called yet available blocks
which actually is linked to this
description and this is from Stack
Overflow ah right so this this piece of
code this snippet of code was described
is get free space on internal memory and
we will not be able to understand that
they actually get available blocks is
something is exactly related to free
space so the depth is very limited for
unsupervised approach this another
problem is that we face infinite amount
of infinite part of praise of freedom if
we do not restrict our taxonomy so
labeling freedom should be based on a
given text on main in Stack Overflow you
have seen it that you cannot just put
any labels on your questions for example
you have to follow the their own
taxonomy so let me show you the second
the second experiments that we did run
and
in this case we use pretty much the same
libraries for architecture we did go a
bit further because if before we were
mostly looking at the tree structure and
starting a topological mmm deep doing
basically topological analysis of of
course here we were also looking at the
talking and talking level and a
character level and it was we were able
to do that with combination of Aaron and
CNN's and a lsdm this sense plus we
added the detention and we have seen an
amazing improvement in accuracy actually
so easy as you see here we got on a test
set almost almost 90% well actually 88%
here and what is even more interesting
that we got there within a few within a
few walks so what it really means
actually in terms of understanding
what's going on in in code so - such a
such a question what is security related
components the unsurprised moral didn't
show any results really and supervised
one did show this as a relevant piece of
code to be fair for me it doesn't look
as irrelevant to to security one because
I I'm not I was not that familiar with
with with JavaScript but apparently what
it is doing it's it's this line is
restricting the second the session set
cookies to be sent only when HTTPS is
enabled basically just by using HTTPS
and that's why it's being treated as a
security one so this kind of amazing
things you can really do when you
combine those and when you combine these
different approaches and treat the code
in such a manner so the last the last
cool results that I wanted to show you
is when we is basically the scatterplot
graph that represents on how the
different files different snippets of
code within one project change together
so our hypothesis was that if a code is
changed together within one commit that
it means that there is a certain
semantics that is underlying this change
which means that you basically change
these three diff
components you probably edging another
button so the next time you change these
three components again you're probably
adding another but you know something
like that so as you can see the most of
the code actually has quite a lot of
quite a lot of relationship and
correlation between the changes but
there are some outliers and the outliers
sometimes show some amazing results so
this one for example is have this name
look at that do not user you will be
fired at react and Facebook component
and it's not been used with many others
so the same with the very similar with
other outliers
they're basically representation of of
your tagged app and how the code is not
being really very well incorporated or
optimized in certain projects so just
from just from this topological analysis
actually and very simple clustering here
but using the embeddings you can see of
what components I actually have to be
optimized and which components are in a
very good health so basically what I
wanted to finish with is that these are
the first results what a am code is
coming and it's a very very interesting
thing I think there is a lot of treasure
in data that is code and some of the
some of the companies such as Facebook
has some very interesting papers
actually recently about the semantic
search on their code two very company
specific but still Google obviously
Microsoft and others they're already
doing it and it it changes the way and
how they develop the code and I'm
absolutely confident that the alien code
in general will will change the way we
are coding and developing software
projects so keep your eye on it thank
you very much
[Applause]
any questions
yep
you mentioned that yo a I going to fix
bugs but most of prominent bugs come
from not knowing or not understanding
business logic behind the processes
how can a I help here ya know that's a
very good question and I didn't promise
yet that we are going to fix your box
completely listen this send me a pic
exactly actually for this reason so as I
said the the problem right now is with
the depth of understanding and semantics
of what is actually happening in the
code right now we're using the with a
classic or more advanced machine
learning and even sometimes deep
learning still help you to see the
repeated code and study more of the
patterns basically to to fix the box
they have happen again and again and
again and again those that are very
company specific or very business
specific or even happen for the first
time definitely not going to solve
anytime soon but that's the same
actually with with with the generation
of documentation all the code for that
matter I don't think that we will be
able to completely replace software
engineers or data sciences that's for
sure but we can we can definitely take
the most boring part of the job that is
has been repeated and duplicated so many
times and just free up your time and my
time to do a more exciting creative
stuff like fixing a business related box
here
just curious doesn't work better with
different languages or not like
statically typed languages or dynamic
languages or your your model is agnostic
to the programming programming language
itself it's a very good question so
quick answer will be that this approach
is language agnostic but as you have
seen from the diagram you actually
choose you choose the level at which you
want to basically you should be always
very task driven and if you if you're
working just with one language then you
can much faster mmm produce the model
that will be very good with just one
language if you are more interested with
working say with one specific task but
across languages you can just choose a
different type from betting and there
will be that will be probably a strategy
so again there is no silver bullet
everything that I have shown here is as
a result of combination of models so
there is not even a single model that I
can training that will get me this
results really and that's why there is
need for this bit holistic approach that
is then combined with a very task driven
specific one no one else
all right thanks Misha thank you thank
you very much
[Applause]